put this into perspective woman in
devops in 2020
was the fourth highest source
of revenue wow basements interest and
soda
that's big yeah it came higher than any
job board we've invested in
everything so if that doesn't tell you
how commercially viable
you know investing like that purpose
time
and planning i don't i don't know what
will the first thing that jumps to my
mind
is to speak to your candidates and
clients so when you're speaking to
hiring managers
the majority of hiring managers now have
some sort of um
driver towards building a diverse team
and that's like at the forefront of
their targets right so you need to be in
as their recruitment partner to be
competitive and
you know to be a true a true like
extinction to their business you also
need to be in line with their thinking
is utilize your immediate network but
just ask questions like
have difficult conversations and educate
yourself and it's okay
like to to learn and
to like not necessarily understand if
that makes sense but just make sure
you're educating yourself
[Music]